.
HARRIS.
>> Harris: CHAD PERGRAM, THANK
YOU FOR GETTING US STARTED HERE.
SEAN HANNITY IS IN "FOCUS" NOW
RIGHT NEXT TO ME HERE.
>> I DON'T GET TO SEE YOU
ENOUGH.
OUR HOURS ARE SO DIFFERENT.
GREAT TO SEE YOU AND THANK YOU
FOR HAVING ME.
>> Harris: IT IS GOOD.
WE DON'T CONNECT ENOUGH.
THIS IS PERFECT BECAUSE WE'LL
GET SOME GOOD FACE TIME.
LET ME ASK YOU ABOUT THIS
SQUEAKY MAJORITY.
I SAY SQUEAKY TIGHT.
THERE ARE STILL RACES TO BE
CALLED.
IF REPUBLICANS PICK UP MORE,
GREAT.
IT WON'T BE THAT MUCH MORE.
>> MY GUESS IS 222 AFTER I LOOK
AT ALL NUMBERS.
>> Harris: LAY IT OUT FOR ME.
WHAT SHOULD THE PRIORITIES BE
FOR REPUBLICANS NOW.
>> I WOULD REMIND PEOPLE THE
MOMENT YOU SEE THE GAVEL HANDED
FROM PELOSI TO MCCARTHY IS A BIG
MOMENT.
THE LAST CONGRESS PELOSI HAD A
SMALL MAJORITY AND WITNESS WHAT
SHE WAS ABLE TO GET
ACCOMPLISHED.
YOU CANNOT UNDERESTIMATE THE
POWER OF THAT GAVEL AND I THINK
REPUBLICANS LAID DOWN A MARKER
THIS MORNING.
THERE WILL BE SIGNIFICANT
SERIOUS INVESTIGATIONS.
IF YOU GO BACK, I THINK IT IS
JOE BIDEN MADE DEFINITIVE
STATEMENTS THAT HE NEVER HAD A
CONVERSATION WITH HIS SON,
HUNTER, ABOUT HIS FOREIGN
BUSINESS DEALINGS.
WE KNOW THAT'S NOT TRUE.
A VICE PRESIDENT WOULD NEVER
LEVERAGE A BILLION DOLLARS OF
TAXPAYER MONEY TO GET A
PROSECUTOR IN UKRAINE FIRED AND
TURNS OUT HIS SON IS BEING PAID
MILLIONS AND HE GOES ON "GOOD
MORNING AMERICA" AND ADMITS HE
HAS NO EXPERIENCE AT ALL
WHATSOEVER.
WE KNOW IN RUSSIA WE HAVE THE
FORMER FIRST LADY OF MOSCOW AND
KNOW ABOUT THE 3 1/2 MILLION
DOLLARS BUT ALSO $1 HUNDRED
MILLION INVESTMENT SHE MADE INTO
HUNTER'S FINANCIAL INVESTMENTS
ESPECIALLY REAL ESTATE.
YOU HAVE ALL SORTS OF STUFF
GOING ON IN CHINA.
YOU HAVE A CHINESE NATIONAL
TAKING HUNTER BIDEN AND HIS
FAMILY ON A $1 HUNDRED THOUSAND
SHOPPING SPREE.
THE 1.5 BILLION DEAL WITH THE
BANK OF CHINA.
ONE STEP FURTHER.
THE F.B.I. HAS HAD HUNTER'S
LAPTOP FOR A LONG TIME.
THIS WILL BE ANOTHER
INVESTIGATION THAT JIM JORDAN
WILL BE CONDUCTING.
WHAT WE KNOW IS THAT HE IM ME
INDICATES REPEATEDLY HIS FATHER,
TONY BOBULINSKI WILL BE ON
HANNITY TONIGHT, TONY BOBULINSKI
WAS IN MEETINGS WITH HUNTER AND
JOE BIDEN TALKING ABOUT HIS
FOREIGN BUSINESS AFFAIRS.
WHAT I THINK -- WHERE I THINK
THIS ULTIMATELY GOES PROBABLY
THE BIGGEST PAY TO PLAY SCANDAL
IN THE HISTORY OF THE COUNTRY.
>> Harris: SEAN, WHAT PEOPLE
CARE ABOUT MOST WITH REGARD TO
THIS IS DOES IT TOUCH THE
PRESIDENT?
IF IT DOES, IT PUTS US AS A
NATION IN A CAPITULATEED
POSITION POTENTIALLY WITH
FOREIGN GOVERNMENTS.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT WAS DONE.
IT COULD EVEN BE A NATIONAL
SECURITY ISSUE.
>> I'VE BEEN BRINGING THIS UP
FOR THE LONGEST PERIOD OF TIME.
I DO BELIEVE THE BIDEN FAMILY IS
COMPROMISED.
IT MADE NO SENSE TO END THE
KEYSTONE XL PIPELINE AND LETTING
PUTIN BUILD THE IN ORDER STREAM
TWO PIPELINE .  I DON'T THINK
THE PRESIDENT HAS ANY POWER WITH
CHINA.
IF YOU GO TO THE LAPTOP THERE
ARE NUMEROUS REFERENCES THAT
HUNTER HIMSELF MAKES IMPLICATING
HIS OWN FATHER, THE BIG GUY,
COMPLAINING ABOUT HAVING TO PAY
FOR REPAIRS AT HIS HOUSE.
HE TAKES HALF MY INCOME.
10%, 15% FOR THE BIG GUY.
>> Harris: WHAT YOU JUST SAID,
YOU SAID TWO THINGS -- THREE
THINGS I WROTE DOWN.
STATEMENTS BY THE PRESIDENT.
WHEN YOU SAY DEFINITIVE
STATEMENTS WE HAVE THEM ON
VIDEO.
WE HAVE RECEIPTS OF THAT.
YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT DOESN'T HAVE ANY POWER
WITH CHINA.
DIDN'T WE JUST SEE THAT PLAY OUT
ON A WORLD STAGE?
I WANT TO GET TO THIS.
ONE TOP PRIORITY FOR THE NEW
MAJORITY HOUSE REPUBLICANS IS TO
BATTLE PRESIDENT BIDEN'S RADICAL
GREEN AGENDA WITH THE GOAL OF
CREATING AMERICAN ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE AND IN THE NEAR
TERM LOWERING ENERGY COSTS FOR
STRUGGLING FAMILIES.
HERE IS LARRY KUDLOW.
>> THE BIDEN'S RADICAL CLIMATE
CHANGE CENTRAL PLANNING POLICIES
THAT THEY WANT TO WIPE OUT OIL
AND GAS AND SOMEHOW SUBSTITUTE
WITH WINDMILLS AND SOLAR WOULD
NEVER HAVE THE POWER TO FIRE UP
OUR GREAT FACTORIES AND PLANTS.
SOMETHING IS WRONG WITH THAT
THINKING.
>> Harris: THE GOVERNMENT'S
ENERGY AGENCY SAYS HOME HEATING
OIL IN THE UNITED STATES IS
EXPECTED TO JUMP BY 45% THIS
WINTER AND DIESEL PRICES ALREADY
SKY HIGH ARE GOING TO EXPLODE
WELL OVER $5 A GALLON THROUGH
THE END OF THE YEAR.
TODAY IT'S 5.34 A GALLON.
WE COULD HEAR PROBABLY SIX.
PROGRESSIVE DEMOCRATS ARE
PUSHING FOR THE ADMINISTRATION
TO GO EVEN FURTHER ON CLIMATE.
IN A LETTER TO THE CLIMATE CZAR,
JOHN KERRY, WHO LOVES TO TAKE
PRIVATE JETS AND HAS A HUGE
CARBON FOOTPRINT.
HE SHOULD BE ASHAMED OF HIMSELF.
WE HAVE BOTH A MORAL AND
STRATEGIC RESPONSIBILITY, HE
SAYS, TO PROVIDE COMPREHENSIVE
SUPPORT FOR COUNTRIES FACING
CLIMATE DISASTER INCLUDING DEBT
FORGIVENESS AND REPARATIONS.
WE COULD SPEND A WHOLE HOUR ON
JOHN KERRY AND HIS HYPOCRISY.
LET'S FOCUS IN --
>> AT THE CONFERENCES THE PLACE
IS FULL OF PRIVATE JETS AND THEY
ARE EATING EXPENSIVE ANGUS BEEF
AT THE CONFERENCES ALSO, WHICH
IS FUNNY.
I WILL SAY THIS AND MAYBE YOU
CAN EXPLAIN IT TO ME BECAUSE IT
MAKES NO SENSE TO ME.
IF THE ISSUE OF CLIMATE IS ABOUT
WE WANT TO PROTECT THE EARTH,
THAT'S THEIR ARGUMENT.
IF THAT'S THEIR GOAL SOMEBODY
HAS TO EXPLAIN TO ME WHY IT IS
OKAY TO IMPORT OIL FROM RUSSIA
TO SEND EMISSARIES TO DEAL WITH
COUNTRIES LIKE VENEZUELA TO TRY
TO MAKE A DEAL WITH IRAN TO BEG
OPEC AND JOE BIDEN BEG THE
SAUDIS FOR OIL WHEN WE HAVE MORE
DOMESTIC ENERGY RESOURCES THAN
ANY OTHER COUNTRY ON THE FACE OF
THE EARTH.
IF YOU WANT TO FIX OUR INFLATION
PROBLEM AND LOWER THE PRICE OF
DIESEL, YOU WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT PEOPLE DON'T HAVE TO PAY A
45% INCREASE HEATING THEIR HOMES
THIS WINTER THE BEST THING WE
CAN DO IS ACCEPT THE REALITY IN
THE NEAR TERM DEFINED BY DECADES
WE DON'T HAVE ANY OTHER
ALTERNATIVE.
IT IS THE LIFEBLOOD OF THE
WORLD'S ECONOMY.
>> Harris: YOU SAID THE
PRESIDENT DOESN'T HAVE POWER
WITH CHINA.
I ARGUE THE PRESIDENT DOESN'T
HAVE POWER WITH THE GREEN -- THE
GREEN ADVOCATES.
>> THE CLIMATE ALL ALARMIST
CULT IN CONGRESS.
>> Harris: ALL OF THIS VEEP
DINNER AT THE CLIMATE SUMMIT IN
EGYPT.
THE MENU FEATURED A $1 HUNDRED
PIECE OF ANGUS BEEF AND SEAFOOD
OPTIONS DESPITE PUSHING AN
ANTI-MEAT AGENDA AND BEING KIND
TO ALL THINGS LIVING.
ATTENDEES COULD PURCHASE $125
COCKTAIL BOX WHICH INCLUDED
FOISGRA TO PRODUCE THAT FOOD.
NEXT WEEK INFLATION WILL HIT
AMERICANS HARD.
PRICES OF ALL OF YOUR
THANKSGIVING FOODS, YOUR
FAVORITES, ARE GOING UP
SIGNIFICANTLY OVER LAST YEAR.
EXPERTS PREDICT THE ENTIRE WILL
COST 20% MORE THIS YEAR.
SOME PEOPLE ARE MAKING
DECISIONS, SEAN, I HAVE
INTERVIEWED SOME OF THEM WHERE
WE ARE JUST NOT GOING TO DO
EIGHT DIFFERENT SIDES.
WE'LL DO FOUR.
>> THERE IS A LOT OF TALK ABOUT
PEOPLE BUYING PIZZA AND
FOREGOING THAT TURKEY DINNER.
WHAT'S SAD.
IF WE WOULD REMAIN ENERGY
INDEPENDENT.
IF YOU GIVE ME CHEAPER, CLEANER
ENERGY I'M IN.
TELL ME WHAT IT IS, THOUGH.
WE DON'T HAVE THAT TECHNOLOGY.
WE HAVE NOT ADVANCED IT TO THE
POINT WHERE WE CAN MASS PRODUCE
IT AND WE DON'T HAVE THE
CAPABILITY OF BUILDING GRIDS
UPON IT.
SO IN THE MEANTIME THE LIFEBLOOD
OF THE WORLD'S ECONOMY IS OIL,
GAS AND OIL, PERIOD.
>> Harris: IT FEELS LIKE THE 70s
AND 80s.
IT FEELS LIKE WE MADE NO
PROGRESS EXCEPT FOR TWO YEARS
AGO WE HAD MADE PROGRESS BECAUSE
WE WERE LOOKING AT ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE.
WE SAID IT AT THE SAME TIME.
REAL QUICK YOU MENTIONED GRIDS.
80% OF THE GRIDS IN THIS COUNTRY
ARE SUPPORTED BY FOSSIL FUELS
AND/OR COAL.
THE PRESIDENT IS MAKING DEALS
FOR DIRTY OIL ON THE ONE HAND
AND HE WANTS TO KILL COAL.
I WONDER HOW SENATOR MANCHIN
FEELS ABOUT THE PERSON IN THE
WHITE HOUSE NOW?
>> IF HERSCHEL WALKER WINS IT
WILL BE INTERESTING.
WHEN HE DID A DEAL WITH THE
PRESIDENT HE WAS PROMISED A
PIPELINE.
JUST BEFORE ELECTION BIDEN SAID
NO MORE COAL.
MANCHIN SPOKE OUT FIRMLY.
HE SAID NO MORE DRILLING ONSHORE
OR-OFF SHORE.
THE PEOPLE BEING HURT THE MOST
IN THIS COUNTRY BECAUSE OF THE
ENERGY POLICIES AND THE
FANATICISM ARE POOR AND PEOPLE
ON FIXED INCOMES.
IT WILL KILL THE AMERICAN
ECONOMY.
WE COULD LOWER THE INFLATION
RATE AND SAVE A FORTUNE WHEN WE
FILL UP OUR GAS TANKS.
>> Harris: WE COULD HEAT OUR
HOMES.
>> SO MUCH WE COULD DO.
IT IMPACT EVERYTHING.
I COULD STAY FOR THE WHOLE TWO
HOURS.
>> Harris: YOU DON'T HAVE TO GO
BUT I HA